we can't wait  for all of you to experience the game  thanks again for being with us today and  thanks for all the support you've given  us over the decades especially on this  game it's been an incredible journey for  us making it but we know  that's really only the beginning for  it's when all of you play it that the  real journey begins  and you may be wondering just how big is  this game  so we thought we'd take one last moment  and show you  let's take a look at one of our planets  jemisin  you can land into atlantis  but you can also land and explore  anywhere on the  planet and it's not just this planet  it's all the planets in the system  from barren but resource heavy ice balls  to goldilocks planets with life  and not just this system  but over a hundred systems  over one thousand planets  all open for you to explore  we can't wait  to see what you find  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you